[Music]
what a year this is Banford Carrie
Underwood her music continues to burn up
the country charge like it has done ever
since she won American Idol back in 2005
in fact Gary's got so much to be
thankful for on this special day that we
made a list for it's just all about
memories and you know eating and
celebrating and just being with each
other five things on carries gratitude
list first for husband of six years Mike
Fisher he's a great man and he he is hot
and I think so
and he just has such a great heart and
you know he worked so hard and he's he's
a good husband a good father
number two is their adorable little boy
Isaiah he definitely loves music and he
loves to sing right now he's uh he
started singing um
dirty laundry so it's really cute to
hear him see you know
[Music]
three is the music Karia sold more than
20 million albums for well this one
we're thankful to Kerry for her fashion
parade is always on point so I'm like
what do I feel good in you know that's
that's what it's about when you're
dressing up for any occasion whether
it's dinner out with your spouse or a
red carpet like it's all about feeling
good about yourself and finally Kari
performed a special concert on the
Carnival Vista cruise ship reminding us
that we all should be grateful for the
men and women who keep our country safe
it's important I think for all of us at
some point to just be able to sit back
and say thank you to our military
families
[Music]
you